hello and welcome to the chicky science
show where in this video
we'll address the four major global
problems that we currently face
and how biology in combination with
engineering will help to tackle these
so today's world population is around
7.6 billion this is projected to
increase
to well over 9.5 billion by 2050
this population increase will bring with
it challenges
and demands and these demands can be
split into four different categories
health care water availability energy
supply
and food supply going into a bit more
detail
how can we develop more effective
medicines at a lower cost
and make them more widely accessible how
can we make diagnostics earlier
more accurate and more sensitive or even
better
how can we prevent the arousal of
different diseases in the first place
how will we be able to produce
sufficient clean water
how can we generate more abundance yet
clean energy
and how can we improve the amount of
energy that can be stored
and lastly how can we produce more food
without disrupting the world's
ecological balance
now this list is not exhaustive but many
if not all of these are not novel
problems we faced them before
back in 1798 reverend thomas robert
malthus
a british economist observed that
population growth
inevitably outpaced the growth in food
production
his prediction was therefore that with
population growth
would come widespread outbreaks of
famine war and disease
and these outbreaks would be able to
keep the population growth in check
but only by the deaths of many people
however this turned out not to be the
case
this was because of innovative
technologies that were used to increase
crop yields this included four-field
crop rotation
and the use of fertilizers they made
land more productive
and sense more food into the marketplace
with more foods
the population could grow even more
rapidly than malthus projected
and helped to also meet the workforce
demands of the industrial
revolution this technology-driven
agricultural revolution of the 19th
century
is what susan hockfield refers to as
convergence 1.0
susan hockfield is professor of
neuroscience and president emeritus
at the massachusetts institute of
technology
she describes convergence 1.0 as the
convergence of physics and engineering
the fruits of which we continue to enjoy
today it stems from the agricultural
revolution
to the birth of the electronics industry
that has created our world today
both digitally and computationally
enabled
now i recently listened into a talk
given by susan hockfield and i'm
currently reading her latest book the
age of living machines
how biology will build the next
technology revolution
and this is because we now have a
so-called parts list
from the biological world that includes
the ability to understand
and manipulate the genetic code with
this much better understanding
it stands a chance at being able to
converge with engineering
and the results could be and are
revolutionary
this includes virus-made batteries
protein-based
water filters nanoparticles that can
help detect and cure cancer
and computer-mediated rapid crop
selection
and these are just the tip of the
iceberg in terms of what biology and
engineering in combination could have to
offer
to solve these four major world problems
but there's actually a fifth problem
and that problem is actually being able
to converge biology
with engineering firstly we kind of
speak different languages
and i don't mean english and japanese i
mean
different languages in terms of how we
communicate our understanding
and to the different approaches that we
take in our research disciplines
and so to be able to converge biology
and engineering
there needs to be the funding in place
and the opportunities
for different institutes with different
specialities to be able to combine and
work together
and as i already mentioned i'm currently
reading susan's book
and so i hope to make a video
summarizing the key points from that
book when i finished reading it
and so i guess the point of this video
was just to give you a bit of background
because i think it stands alone as its
own video and
emphasizes as i always like to emphasize
how awesome and cool
biology is oh well science is cool in
general
as i also tweeted earlier anyway on that
note
hopefully you've learned something and
as always thanks for listening and stay
tuned for when i do
finally do a book summary sometime soon